- [Mark] All right, Tee Tee.
- [Tee Tee] Yes.
- [Mark] Tee Tee, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Watts, well, actually,
I stayed in Hollywood.
So I'm kinda half bougie,
half ghetto (laughs).
- [Mark] Okay, and tell
me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- No, I grew up with my grandmother,
and my mom.
My mom was in and out the house.
My dad's, prison, majority of,
my whole life.
- [Mark] Oh, wow.
- I lost my granny at 27,
which was about a year ago.
So I'm kinda adjusting
to not having my granny.
'Cause she always saved
me from everything.
She was really my superhero.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's nice
to have somebody like that
in your life.
- Yes, 'cause no matter what I did,
she had my back 100%.
My mom, on the other hand,
I think my mom's kinda jealous of me,
because she tried
to sleep with one of my baby daddies,
and I didn't understand why,
but my mom has a drinking problem.
So that could be a reason of why.
But, I never really understood my mom,
like, certain things she do,
'cause I think she tries
to hurt me on purpose.
- [Mark] Mm, what age were you
when you left your mom's house?
- 25.
- [Mark] Oh, how old are you now?
- 28, just turned 28,
on the 16th of December.
- [Mark] Happy birthday.
- Thank you (laughs).
- [Mark] Do you have kids of your own?
- Yes, I have five kids.
I have Nuki, which is 11.
I have Nailai, which is eight.
I have Metemeo, which is my dad.
I call him King, which is five.
And Maniyah, which is three.
And my fat dad, which is Zamir,
which he's three months,
gonna be four months.
- [Mark] Oh, you have a baby.
- Yes.
- [Mark] So what are
you doing for money now?
- Occasionally, I catch dates.
I try not to, as often
as some women would,
because I, I'm,
that's really not my lifestyle.
Like, I graduated medical school,
medical assistant/cardiac technician.
I was working at a doctor's office, but,
some kinda way I started thinkin' about
my first two kids getting took
from me, behind marijuana.
And I still haven't figured out how to-
- [Mark] So you lost
your first two children?
- [Tee Tee] Yes, I still don't
know how to cope with that,
because my two kids are actually
with a lesbian White couple,
that are married.
And I'm not okay with that,
but I guess it was for a reason.
- [Mark] Do you ever
see your first two kids?
- [Tee Tee] They won't let me.
They won't let me have no
type of contact with them.
- [Mark] And they were taken away why?
- [Tee Tee] Because of marijuana.
I tested positive for marijuana
when I had my daughter,
and she didn't test positive, but I did.
So they took them from me.
August 15, 2012.
- [Mark] Tell me about
making money dating guys.
What kinda guys do you pick up?
- [Tee Tee] Sometimes, I
might pick up a gentleman.
Sometimes I might pick up an asshole,
excuse my language, but (laughs).
I get paid pretty well, I-
- [Mark] I'll bet you do (laughs).
- [Tee Tee] I could actually say that.
Now the assholes, they try to,
come with the 20 and 40 type of thing,
but majority of the time
when I catch a date,
even if it's at the end of the night,
it'll be like a hundred or more.
- [Mark] I believe that.
- That's the ones I go for.
- [Mark] White guys, Black guys, Hispanic?
- White.
I love me some White men.
I ain't gonna lie.
I love White men, 'cause
they are sweethearts.
Black men, on the other
hand, they assholes.
Some of 'em not,
but majority of 'em are.
- [Mark] Where do you guys go,
to a hotel?
- Well, the White guys
always take me to a hotel.
It'd be an expensive Snooty Fox, Mustang,
or American Inn, or somethin' like that.
Now the Black guys, they,
they more of a car action.
I try to get them out the way, fast,
so I can get away from
them as fast as possible.
- [Mark] In the car?
- Yeah (laughs), but,
my White male friends,
I kinda like them more.
I think, in the long run,
I think I might end up
marryin' a White man.
I'm not sure, but I think that's
what might happen (laughs).
- [Mark] Find a sugar daddy,
and you're all set.
- Yeah, pretty much (laughs).
- [Mark] How do you pick them up?
- I just walk.
I could be walkin' to the store or,
just walkin' down the
street, randomly walking.
And they'll stop and holler at me.
- [Mark] Sure they will, in (laughs),
in this neighborhood?
- Yeah, pretty much (laughs).
- Course they will.
Are you using any drugs?
- Yes, I smoke cavi.
- [Mark] Which is?
- Which is cocaine, crack cocaine.
I'm starting to get kinda tired of it,
which is a good thing for me.
I really don't need a program,
because cocaine is, crack is a mind thing.
And really, truthfully,
all drugs are a mind thing.
If you let it take over you, it will.
If you're strong enough
to fight it, it won't.
Me, on the other hand,
I use cocaine as like,
a numbing medicine.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- It numbs me from,
my kids being gone,
my other three being at home with my mom.
I don't go around my kids high,
because I don't want them to
see their mother like that.
- [Mark] So you're
running around the street
while your mom's taking care of your kids?
- Yes, and I respect her for that.
I love her for that,
because she took on my responsibility
that I used to, once upon a time, have,
which I'm trying to get back to that.
'Cause I miss bein' a mommy.
Even though I know I'm a mom,
I miss bein' a mommy to my kids.
My son, he begs me to come home,
but I can't go around him like that.
I want to be completely clean and sober,
when I go around my babies.
So if I'm high, I won't go home.
When I come down and I'm sober,
is when I go home.
Other than that, I don't go home.
- [Mark] Losing your
grandmother is hard for you.
- Very.
- [Mark] You guys were close.
- Because she died on my
oldest daughter's birthday,
which I was actually on my way to see her.
And they told me that she was expired.
And I didn't know.
And it really fucked me up
that she passed away,
because that was really
the only person I had,
besides my kids.
That's really the only person I had,
that had my back 100%,
no matter what I did.
My granny saved me from everything.
So this is actually my first year,
goin' through this, without my granny.
Woo, I hate when I get emotional (laughs).
(sniffles) But I know
she lookin' down on me.
- [Mark] What would your
grandmother say to you right now?
- She would whoop my ass right now,
I swear to you not.
Now, while I'm sittin' here,
she would be proud of me.
But when I go outside the door (laughs),
she would kick me in my ass, honestly.
Because my granny wanted
me to quit smoking,
and I made a promise to her,
that I was gonna get it together.
And now that it's 2020,
I'm a keep my promise to her,
because she really did care about me.
She really loved me.
She just wanted the best for me.
And just so she know, I do
love you, Granny (laughs).
I love you dearly (sniffles), woo.
- [Mark] All right, Tee Tee,
thank you for-
- You're welcome (sniffles), oh.